it's not a hobby but a lifelong Pursuit
for one Hollywood Legend who gave us a
tour of her breathtaking Gardens
there's a little house on Los Angeles
west side where there's no mistaking
it's spring the thousands of flowers
blooming right now or the passion of a
woman who's the master of it all it's
Paradise this paradise was created by
Julie Newmar who's delighted to share it
with us yes yes welcome welcome your
title I have a title you do I've never
heard of this oh yeah what is the title
Gardener extraordinaire her other titles
may be far better known Julie Newmar was
a dancer
a model and an actress forever known as
the temptress Catwoman in the 1960s TV
series Batman
sweet might get to know each other a
little better through six decades in the
spotlight Newmar held Gardens tight
because of what is deeply rooted in her
childhood that had to do with my father
I think that was the safest and happiest
place for me with my father was in a
garden and he built a playhouse
fountains
so she had fountains built here to stand
alongside more plants and even she can
count this is an unusual bird of
paradise because it doesn't have those
flapping wings and on your right is the
Alice in Wonderland gate no matter where
she was in the world she says she made
sure there were always remnants of that
safe and happy place she knew as a child
well when I lived in New York I had a
penthouse with two balconies around this
side and I won't tell you everything
that I grew in
yeah but there were trees and there were
vines it was beautiful
so you've never lived without never live
without flowers the rigors of working in
the entertainment business for a lot of
people there's ego there's long
stretches of of intensity there's a lot
going on a lot going on what did being a
gardener present for you through that if
there was a problem that I could not
solve I would just come out in the
garden and it just kind of entangles
your nerves it's it's a wonderful place
to be much of her Paradise was designed
for her own child John now 42 with Down
syndrome and nearly death oh he loves it
yeah it just feels his bodily excitement
nature is so perfect in itself that for
me this is healing on Earth for John and
for herself there are plenty of
childlike places to discover I found
your secret garden that was for my son
right here see
and all the sculptures are made to order
it's me really about 10 years old but
it's an ongoing thing that's what's
wonderful it's like life you keep on
enriching your own life and the flowers
tell you where they want to be how long
did it take to create this I don't want
to say how long I've been here for three
decades at least going on four at every
turn there's something new what have you
found now donkey's tale you have more
Garden back here do go down there I'll
meet you on the other side an avalanche
of roses is on the other side she has
more than 80 different varieties each
bush has its own Spirits it name those
are the famous Jacqueline Dupre she was
the great cellist jump for joy and
pumpkin patch and of course there's this
one the Julie Newmar roses ever the
performer
Julie newmar's latest production are her
online Garden videos being a dancer and
or a choreographer we see things in
movement
so you get a kind of shape of things and
then when you have a small space it's
very good to create curves rather than
straight lines because then your eye
goes out of the garden did Dancing
Inspire the garden it has to it's a
piece of choreography this summer she
turns 90 her long life has clearly left
her unwaveringly optimistic aren't we
lucky to have this time on Earth Mars
maybe but the Earth yes that's so
exciting because she's remained devoted
to the safe and happy place her father
introduced her to so long ago
89 years young still moving around that
Garden was
brilliant you can lose yourself in it I
asked her I said isn't there a drought
going on in Los Angeles she's like no
they got a lot of rings they did but for
30 years that Garden has you know gone
through the constant growth and
transformation and she's nursed it the
entire 30 years there's certainly
healing powers within it